endless questions for the families of
three fishermen
who never came home carl mcgrath ross
ballentine and alan minard
were on a fishing trip in late january
what happened to them
and why they never returned is still a
mystery
he actually built the boat and he worked
hard day and night
carl's mother julie is desperate for
answers
he just sat there day in day out waiting
for some news and it's horrible it's
just horrible waiting
and you're longing for it you're just
longing for them to say look we found
them
and that's what i'm longing for you know
to get that
so we can put you know we want to put
carl at peace we want to
lay him to rest the families of all
three have sought help from the ocean
recovery expert
who found wreckage of the plane carrying
footballer emiliano sala
they're hoping to raise 75 000 pounds to
pay for the private search
we know times against us um so we
decided to say
to raise the money for this for this
private search with david murns who's um
been advising us along the way um so we
started
that off two weeks ago we're currently
up to four forty thousand just over
which is absolutely incredible
the families say they can't start
grieving until their boys
come home this is conway key in north
wales and it's from here
that ross carl and allen set sail on
board a boat that carl built with his
own hands
the weather conditions that day were
described as moderate
a perfect day for sailing this video is
from the boat's maiden voyage
the nikola faith a 33-foot vessel
sailed what's believed to be its final
journey on january 27th
its gps last located it at 6 pm that
evening
the alarm was raised the following
morning after the boat failed to return
a search covering hundreds of square
miles off the north wales coast
was eventually called off
then last week the boat's life raft was
found 19 nautical miles from here
in scotland none of the raft's equipment
had been used
the families say life is in limbo as
they wait for answers
the private search is set to begin next
week
their search for closure depends on it
sadia chowdhury sky news
in north wales